[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à l'arrivée des galets
au salon de dubaï de chopes suivez moi
[Musique]
je m'appelle johan caroupaye j'habite au
port j'ai 27 ans et je crée la société
doit d'un bac de chopes le 16 avril 2020
alors avant de créer la société j'ai
travaillé ici pendant six ans dans un
bar bioshock situé dans la ville du port
j'étais responsable et j'étais en cdi et
tue sa mère acquis des expériences et
par la suite et ça m'a encouragé à créer
mon entreprise
par rapport à potentiel de clients que
j'avais et du coup j'ai sollicité pas ma
d'organismes comme la boutique de
gestion m'a conseillé de subventions taz
hauteur de huit mille euros c'est 1
subventions qu'il faut pas négliger
parce que ces données par le département
et aussi le pôle emploi aussi m'a
beaucoup aidé pour l'indemnisation de
l'assedic
c'est on va dire que c'est un récompense
de mon travail
dambach bishop est un salon
en coiffure bien implantée dans la ville
de large du port à l'arrivée des galets
dans une zone prioritaire car c'est
prioritaire aussi nous proposons
plusieurs types de prestations coupe aux
moeurs coupe enfants coupe à la garçonne
également aux barbes shampoing et
plusieurs types de prestations
95% de nos clients sont satisfaits avec
de très bonnes reçoit et on est élu l'un
des meilleurs salons à la réunion sur
200 salons en 2020 par rapport déjà à
nos tarifs abordables et aussi on est
beaucoup sollicité par des jeunes avec
les coupes tendances actuelles des
dégradés dessin rasoir on a commencé
dans un an dans un période très
difficile que le commis 19 mai après le
travail a payé l'état la qualité et la
qualité des prestations a fait que les
clients avaient
venez en bout et cela a donné un réel
potentiel
depuis l'ouverture de mon entreprise
j'ai créé huit emplois j'ai créé deux
cdi des cdd et quatre apprentis c'est
des gens qui étaient demandeurs d'emploi
qui va dire qu'ils galéré être dans un
quartier près l'état n'est pas toujours
facile pour moi c'était important déjà
de solliciter les jeunes de la région
avant tout est de privilégier ces jeunes
là et c'est déjà lui qui sont motivés
surtout motivés j'aimerais implanter mon
ancien dans chaque région cioni pour
pouvoir privilégier les jeunes des
quartiers où l'ancien sera implanté et
créer beaucoup plus d'emplois pour des
jeunes qui sont motivés le meilleur a
fait arriver dans notre présence est pas
le résultat du travail dans un moulin
mais c'est le travail en équipe